Nobody likes you.
No one likes you,
but you,
I have a,
you do survive pretty well.
You'd be better off being a half Alina.
What's a have Alina to peccary.
What's a peccary?
It's like your cousin to a pig.
What's a pig?
You ever see that?
Hallelujah.
Doug lives,
you know Doug lives in Bisbee,
Arizona.
Stan hope.
Um,
who by the way,
I think it's so,
it's sold out,
but he's taping his,
uh,
his next special in Vegas next month.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah.
In Vegas.
That's cool.
Where he lives in Bisbee like he basically that's there to have Lena.
He lives really close to the border.
Like I think he's the only,
like six miles from the border or some crazy shit.
Um,
and um,
these things live in the wild,
out in the desert.
Right.
Fucking they're aggressive and they fucked up his neighbor's dog.
They killed his neighbor's dog.
No.
Yeah,
man,
the dog was out and the Havoline is,
will flanking.
Look,
they'd get on both sides of it and they,
they uh,
hunting in a pack.
Yeah.
They hunt in the pack and they will attack a small dog
that thinks disgusting.
Gross.
That's,
that's like a giant rat.
It looks like a giant rat.
Well,
it does look so it looks like a pig fucked around.
Oh,
somebody shot in the face.
Crossbow.
People hunt them all the time.
It looks like a pig.
Fucked a rat.
I see.
That got shot.
One where it does look like a pig.
Fucked around.
Click on the guy who shot one.
Yeah.
Bow and Arrow.
A lot of guys a hunt them with archery equipment.
See,
wouldn't it be better if he was dressed in like a coat with a tie?
None of those boots.
No,
because you don't want that thing to see you look at that.
That's a rat face.
Oh,
that is not a giant body scroll.
Scroll back to that last one and make it bigger again.
Yeah.
That guy is hunting rats teeth.
That's like a slightly different looking rat.
Oh,
you want to know what's really crazy rat.
That's a hundred pound rat.
Yeah.
Without a tail.
That's so gross.
And you know what's really crazy is those animals,
um,
they'll,
they're the best animal to a call.
Now what a call is,
is like you'd made us make a sound of a wounded animal.
No,
you make like,
like something that's stopped suffering.
Like people take their hand,
these fuckers run in,
they run in.
Yes.
There's so aggressive.
It's crazy watching.
Something's hurting.
I can go eat it but they have to act quick cause there's coyotes out there and
mountain lions out there.
So when something's hurting here like fuck food and they just run towards it.
So when your bow hunting,
you almost have to have one person make the call and you're at full draw and
then they start calling and the things come running in and you shoot at him.
Yeah.
Cause you couldn't do it.
You couldn't get to the boat for a long time cause they'd see you and they go
fuck it.
The guy turn off the other way again.
Yeah.
Are these like invasive or are they all over his property?
No,
they're natural.
They're nobody.
I mean are they not invasive?
But I mean,
is there a lot of them?
Yes.
There's like a ton of ram where he lives exist.
Yeah.
I mean they exist in the desert.
I mean they,
they exist and healthy enough populations that you,
people hunt for them.
Wow.
And they eat them.
They say it takes you.
Yeah.
That was neat.
That you eed to pig.
Yeah,
but they're cuter.
Wild boar.
Yeah.
Crazy tusks looking.
Yeah,
those are gross too.
Pretty gross to my pigs.
My cakes.
I believe this.
The ones I eat have bow ties around this guy's garage and little tap shoes.
Sometimes I hat I do this shit down,
Bro.
They're staring him down there in his garage.
There's a whole bunch of them.
Fuck.
Is that all right on your kid's toy?
Look at is.
It's all it's hair's up in any way.
Look at that.
Just going to take a dump in your driveway.
Who'd you do not want that in your life?
I don't want to live there.
There's fucking 20 of them in this guy's driveway.
See that one there in the back.
How to grow that back again.
How many were there?
There was like 12 what is the name of that video for?
People want to watch it wild.
Have Belina's make a visit to Arizona home.
Why?
Yeah,
no,
no.
I know you can't show it though.
Those fucking things are everywhere.
There's a lot of them with the wild,
many of them,
they're off seven,
eight at least.
At least eight.
And then there's the one that was on top of the,
there's nine and then there's one that was on top of the truck and there was one
that you could see through the fence.
Yeah.
And there's probably more out there to what's going on in the car.
It's going into the kids.
A little car.
Jesus Christ.
It's in the passenger seat of the car.
Oh,
gross.
Fucking creeps like wild have.
Alina is like a Dean Martin Song.
You think so?
Look over there.
Look.
Oh Man.
They're weird looking too.
They look like they're demons.
I don't like them at all.
The little beady eyes like they're up to no good.
But if you were a little kid,
you thinking like,
I wouldn't live there because that's there.
But if you live in New York,
if you at night,
who knows what's climbing all around your building,
right.
Could be eagles and shit.
Right.
So if you're talking about,
oh,
Google,
hide around,
get into my house in a Google.
Have Alina eats baby.
Let's see if that's ever happened.
Yeah.
Human Baby.
Let's see if that happened.
What do you think if I have Alina eight.
A human.
Yeah.
Like do you see those fucking things?
20 in that guy's drought.
They've definitely gotten babies.
I'm exaggerating.
Wasn't 20 someone's eating a baby right now.
Probably 13 it was probably 12 Baker's dozen.
Baker's does have Evalina.
Yeah,
they would eat a baby.
A toddler.
Yeah.
Knock it down.
I mean,
if they eat a dog,
yeah,
they're scared of people obviously weren't scared of that dude.
Now that's a full brown person and the baby doesn't happen.
It doesn't have anything.
I know.
I put it the hair up spikes up to let you know.
It's threatened to ever tell you the story.
When I pulled a rat out of my,
uh,
pool vacuum.
Yeah.
Was it alive?
No.
Did Stink.
It had,
it stunk.
I'm like,
why isn't the vacuum working?
Did you think about it?
I dove in and I pulled it up and there was a half a rat.
It's asked,
sticking out the vacuum,
and as soon as I got it above the water flies,
just
pull it out without it.
There's a question king,
where the fuck are the flies before the shit?
Good question.
Where are the fuck are they all over there?
Not that many.
Like if you,
if you are around by a person's backyard.
Yeah.
How often do you see flies?
Every now and then.
This one,
it's kind of annoying,
but if you just pulled your pants down,
shat on the ground,
it would be flies on that within a matter of moments.
Oh,
you mean right after I swam you swam shaft right on their law.
I mean you're after swim shit.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden they show up.
It's disgusting and it happened so fast.
So gross.
All of a sudden they're all waiting.
Yeah.
Where'd you guys come from?
We should just stay inside.
Did you find a baby death from us?
Have Alina.
A couple of months ago,
it's a couple people in Arizona were attacked and they had like old woman was
bit while she was walking her dog and another guy was bit while he was feeding
them and he didn't feed it fast enough and it met them.
That's about as much as I could.
Fine.
Well the lady who got bit,
that's the scary one because the guy who fed them was an asshole.
Right.
This Gary one through there was a lady got bit by a coyote recently in Dallas
though.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah it was around the Dallas area.
I think they think that this is one coyote that's been biting people.
It's a rogue unusual coyote snapping at people who freely.
Yeah,
they had bite marks on their legs.
Oh my God,
that's gross man.
Cause they will kill you if they would kill you.
They're just small.
They're just not sure if it's worth the effort and you're around people and
they're worried that you know one on one cause you fight off a coyote man.
I mean I think you probably could if you had to,
but they'll fuck you up man.
Just keep biting.
There's a few of them.
That's where the real problem comes.
If they bite you in the right spot.
Yeah man,
the rip your tendons apart.
You won't be able to run away.
They know what they're doing to
try to take your legs out and they know what they're doing.
They're not going to try to jump up and bite you in the neck.
They're going to try and take your,
your hamstrings out,
right?
Yeah.
Trying to rip your legs apart so you can't run.
Why are they so mean?
That's how they're alive.
You're not leaving any food out for him or you know,
you've got to do what they gotta do.
It's called domestication.
That's how we have dogs.
Do you ever take your family camping?
I have not.
Yeah,
I haven't either.
I would though.
I wanted to take my kids to Yosemite cause I love Yosemite to bring a peace sign
arm.
Nothing.
Nothing just went solo.
We weren't camping.
We were staying in it and we're staying in.
And then what about emergency food?
No satellite phone.
Nothing.
Just a phone.
First Aid kit.
Nothing.
A bag of Funyuns and an iPhone.
That's all I need and I want to show them Yosemite cause it's such a great part
of my life.
I love it.
I've been lived in the back country for like a week at a time.
I just love the whole thing and I telling them about it and I'm building it up.
They were like,
you know,
begrudgingly going.
They're all vegetarians.
They just love nature.
They just love whatever.
So I'm like,
you're going to love Yosemite.
As soon as we drove into the park,
welcome to Yosemite.
I ran over a squirrel.
The horror inside the car.
Dad,
you didn't even slow down.
What's row?
You're a monster.
I'm like,
I can't.
It's two lanes.
There's a guy behind me.
A guy in front,
I guess would steamroll the squirrel.
They were,
oh,
they were in the whole weekend.
Anytime.
I'd be like,
look at this.
Look at this beautiful view.
You killed a squirrel.
You didn't even care.
That's the weird part.
Dang.
You didn't even care.
Is that what they're saying?
Yeah,
we were supposed to cry.
I was just laughing.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's wanting to be killed.
A deer.
You'd be Saturday,
right?
Yeah.
God dammit.
Can't believe that.
I can't believe how beautiful.
She was so nice with their little lies and the little tail.
This girl peccary.
Yeah.
If you kill them Havalinas like you have to fucking rat thing.
I find it's mom that have Alina would ruin your arch to bite your teeth.
Could probably use its teeth to tear your tires apart.
Then you missed talking the side of the road,
trying to change the tire.
You turn around,
there's a whole pack of them closing in on you.
Would you not take your family because of all of this van?
Do you not want them in the woods with you?
What am I a danger in the woods or become a werewolf?
What the fuck?
He just got to snap Internet.
Trust me.
I'll be right back.
Not that you're the threat,
Ron,
that you'd have to protect them from all the threats.
Well,
I mean,
Yosemite doesn't have that many threats other than people bears black bears then
yeah.
Most of mountain lions,
mountain lions are an issue.
There's always something out there.
Yeah.
Grizzly bears or you're just,
you're just don't feel like that's a cause.
You like going out into nature.
You go to the toilet stuff.
I do like going into nature.
I also like being indoors,
like sleeping in a place where it's awesome to sleep.
People wiser than may have figured out that that maneuver is called a bed with a
roof and a locked door and a refrigerator.
You fucking cave person.
Oh,
I'm going to rough it.
I'm going to sleep on the ground.
You don't have to,
did you know that sleep in a house.